MEAN FOR THE GENERAL ELECTION?
WE HAVE SIX MONTHS TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
>> JEFF ZELENY, THANKS SO MUCH.
KRISTEN, LET ME START WITH YOU.
OHIO WAS THE FIRST MAJOR TEST OF
TRUMP'S INFLUENCE.
HAVE BEEN SOME OTHER RACES SINCE
HE LEST OFFICE, AND HE HAS A
MORE MIXED RECORD.
BUT MAJOR TEST IN THE 2022
MIDTERMS HE PASSED.
THERE'S STILL MORE THAN A HALF
DOZEN RACES COMING UP WITH TRUMP
ENDORSED CANDIDATES IN NEBRASKA,
IN NORTH CAROLINA, IN
PENNSYLVANIA, IN IDAHO AND
GEORGIA.
DO YOU THINK ALL OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS JD
VANCE?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT ALL OF THEM
WILL BE.
CERTAINLY, THIS IS GOOD NEWS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IF HE WANTED TO
DISRUPT THIS NARRATIVE THAT
MAYBE HIS ENDORSEMENTS DON'T
MEAN MUCH, JD VANCE REALLY DOES
HAVE TO THANK DONALD TRUMP FOR
ELEVATING HIM IN THAT PRIMARY.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
DR. OZ IS GOING TO HAVE AN EASY
PATH TO VICTORY IN PENNSYLVANIA.
IT DOESN'T MEAN BRIAN KEMP IS
SUDDENLY IN MASSIVE JEOPARDY IN
GEORGIA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PLACES WHERE
THE PRESIDENT'S INFLUENCE
REMAINS MORE LIMITED.
AND FRANKLY, YOU CAN LOOK AT
THIS GLASS HALF FULL AND SAY HE
CLEARLY GOT VANCE TO THE FRONT
IN THAT PACK, BUT THE OTHER WAY
TO LOOK AT IT IS ALMOST 7 IN 10
OHIO REPUBLICAN PRIMARY VOTERS
DID NOT LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT.
SO THERE'S A WAY YOU CAN SPIN
THIS TO BOTH SAY TRUMP HAS A LOT
OF INFLUENCE AND SAY HIS
INFLUENCE IS LIMITED.
>> HE'S GOOD FOR 33% OF THE VOTE
IN A STATE IN WHICH HE DID VERY
WELL.
IN OHIO.
SO IN A CROWDED FIELD, OF
COURSE, THAT MAKES A LARGE
DIFFERENCE.
BUT WHAT WILL IT BE IN A
GOVERNOR'S RACE, FOR EXAMPLE?
YOU MENTIONED KEMP VERSUS
PERDUE, HIS CANDIDATE, PERDUE,
IS NOT DOING TOO WELL IN THE
POLLS RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IT'S GLASS HALF FULL,
HALF EMPTY.
AS YOU POINT OUT, YOU CAN
ANALYZE IT ANY WAY YOU WANT.
>> HE'S GOING TO FACE TIM RYAN,
IN THE SENATE RACE IN OHIO.
JD VANCE SAYS TIM RYAN IS TRYING
TO BE A TRUMP DEMOCRAT.
HERE'S WHAT RYAN HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I'M AN AMERICAN.
LOOK, I AGREED WITH DONALD TRUMP
ON CHINA, ON A FEW OTHER ISSUES.
BUT YOU KNOW, AND I HAVE
DISAGREED WITH DEMOCRATS ON
STUFF.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, RAN AGAINST
NANCY PELOSI, GOT IN FIGHTS WITH
BERNIE SANDERS, DISAGREED WITH
OBAMA ON TPP.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT.
I'M REPRESENTING THE EXHAUSTED
MAJORITY HERE.
AND THE EXHAUSTED MAJORITY WANTS
TO STOP THE WASHINGTON, D.C.
FOOD FIGHT.
THEY WANT US TO START WORKING
TOGETHER.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I MEAN, I THINK HE'S DOING
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO WIN IN A
STATE LIKE OHIO.
HE'S NOT UNLIKE A LOT OF
VULNERABLE U.S. SENATORS, WELL,
VULNERABLE CANDIDATES FOR U.S.
SENATE IN SWING STATES AND
STATES THAT YOU CAN'T GO TOO FAR
TO THE LEFT.
AND STATES WHERE BEING PERCEIVED
AS TOO ALIGNED WITH NANCY PELOSI
MIGHT NOT WIN YOU THE VOTES YOU
NEED.
SO AGAIN, I THINK HE'S, LIKE ANY
OTHER CANDIDATE, DOING WHAT HE
SAYS HE NEEDS TO DO TO CONNECT
WITH VOTERS.
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
BECAUSE OHIO IS A STATE THAT
RIGHT NOW IS TRENDING RED.
>> IT'S VERY RED.
IT'S A VERY RED STATE.
BUT WE SHOULD POINT OUT, THE
OTHER SENATOR IN OHIO IS SHERROD
BROWN, WHO IS ONE OF THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE.
>> RIGHT, AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
TO YOUR POINT, HE IS SAYING,
RYAN IS SAYING WHAT HE NEEDS TO
SAY.
IN ORDER TO APPEAL TO HIS
VOTERS.
BUT I THINK ONE OTHER THING HE
CAN POINT OUT IS THE ISSUE WITH
JD VANCE ABOUT HOW WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT EARLIER.
HE USED TO BE A COMMENTATOR ON
THIS NETWORK.
HE WAS VERY ANTI-TRUMP.
HE TALKED ABOUT TRUMP AS BEING
CULTURAL HEROIN.
HE TALKED ABOUT TRUMP AS LEADING
THE WHITE WORKING CLASS DOWN A
VERY DARK PATH.
AND HE IS NOW DOING THAT.
AND SO I THINK WE'RE AT A POINT
WHERE TIM RYAN CAN POINT OUT THE
PERNICIOUS NATURE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT JUST ENDORSED BY DONALD
TRUMP BUT WHO HAVE LEFT THEIR
VALUES IN THE GARBAGE TO FOLLOW
THIS MAN WHO HAS BEEN SO
DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> I DO WANT TO SWITCH JUST TO
TALK ABOUT ABORTION FOR A SECOND
BECAUSE OF OBVIOUSLY THAT
SEISMIC STORY THAT POLITICO
WROTE YESTERDAY WHERE IT LOOKS
AS THOUGH THE SUPREME COURT IS
POISED TO OVERTURN ROE V. WADE
ALTOGETHER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
CONVINCED THIS WILL BE A MAJOR
MOTIVATOR FOR DEMOCRATIC VOTERS,
FOR WOMEN VOEPTERS WHO SUPPORT
ABORTION RIGHTS.
THERE'S AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT
WHO DISAGREES.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO SENATOR
JOE MANCHIN FROM WEST VIRGINIA.
>> INFLATION IS THE NUMBER ONE
DRIVING FACTOR, I BELIEVE, IN MY
STATE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S HURTING EVERYBODY.
JUST AT THE PUMP, BUT AT THE
GROCERY STORE, AT THE DRUGSTORE,
AT THE PHARMACEUTICAL,
EVERYTHING THEY DO.
SO MANY SERIOUS ISSUES.
>> AND LOOK, MANCHIN IS NOT A
SUPPORTER OF ABORTION RIGHTS,
BUT IS HE WRONG?
>> I THINK WE DON'T KNOW YET.
I DON'T WANT TO BE WISHY-WASHY
ON THIS, BUT I THINK THAT THERE
ARE DEMOCRATS, I WAS TALKING TO
A DEMOCRATIC POLLSTER TODAY, AND
HE SAID TO ME, LOOK, IF THE
DEMOCRATS LEAN INTO WHAT
HAPPENED ON ABORTION, IF THE
DEMOCRATS LEAN INTO THESE
SO-CALLED RADICAL REPUBLICANS,
AND YOU HAVE HEARD THE PRESIDENT
TALK ABOUT THAT A LOT NOW.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT IT TODAY,
YEAH.
>> THEN AND PRIVACY, THIS
QUESTION OF PRIVACY, HE SAYS IF
THE -- THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
ORGANICALLY.
IF CANDIDATES DECIDE THEY'RE
DOING TO LEAN INTO IT, THEY CAN
REALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
WITH VOTERS.
NOT JUST SUBURBAN WOMEN, BUT IF
THEY DON'T, THAT'S IT.
>> AND TIA, HERE'S VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS AT AN
EVENT LAST NIGHT FOR EMILY'S
LIST.
YOU WERE THERE COVERING IT.
LEANING INTO IT, AS GLORIA MIGHT
SAY.
>> THOSE REPUBLICAN LEADERS WHO
ARE TRYING TO WEAPONIZE THE USE
OF THE LAW AGAINST WOMEN, WELL,
WE SAY HOW DARE THEY.
HOW DARE THEY TELL A WOMAN WHAT
SHE CAN DO AND CANNOT DO WITH
HER OWN BODY?
HOW DARE THEY.
HOW DARE THEY TRY TO STOP HER
FROM DETERMINING HER OWN FUTURE?
>> WE ONLY HAVE A MINUTE LEFT
AND I WANT TO GET TO ALL THREE
OF YOU.
>> I WANT TO SAY QUICKLY, JUST
BECAUSE ABORTION MAY NOT BE THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT A WOMAN
MIGHT SAY SHE CARES ABOUT MOST
DOESN'T MEAN IT CAN'T DRIVE
TURNOUT.
IT CAN'T DRIVE ENTHUSIASM, AND
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS KNOW,
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW IN HER
SPEECH.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT NUMBER ONE.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT CAN GET PEOPLE
TO TURN OUT AND HEAD TO THE
POLLS.
>> IT'S PERSONAL.
AND WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO
LEAN.
THESE DEMOCRATS AREN'T GOING TO
JUST LEAN.
THEY'RE TIPPING OVER ON THIS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S GOING TO
BE A MOTIVATOR.
POLLS HAVE SHOWN, THEY HAVE
ASKED THE QUESTION, IF ROE V.
WADE IS IN DANGER OF BEING
OVERTURNED ARE YOU MORE
MOTIVATED TO VOTE FOR A
DEMOCRAT.
THE ANSWER IS I THINK TWO-THIRDS
OR THREE-FIFTH OR A HIGH NUMBER,
THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY YES.
THIS GOES FOR ALL DEMOGRAPHICS,
WOMEN, MEN, DEMOCRATS,
INDEPENDENTS, LATINOS, BLACKS,
AAPI, ALL ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> WHAT DO THE POLLS SAY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I STILL THINK INFLATION IS
NUMBER ONE ISSUE, BUT THE
ASYMMETRIC WAY IN WHICH THIS
WILL MOTIVATE DEMOCRATS MORE
THAN REPUBLICANS, ANGER AND
FRUSTRATION IS MORE MOTIVATIONAL
THAN, HEY, WE GOT WHAT OUR SIDE
WANTED.
I COULD SEE THIS BEING ASEMITIC
IN TERMS OF WHO IS MOTIVATED.
>> PERHAPS FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER.
IT USUALLY WORKS THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE MOTIVATED BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORT ABORTION RIGHTS, WE HAVE
IT, WE'RE FINE.
>> I THINK ABOUT THIS IN 2018
AROUND KAVANAUGH, THERE WAS THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM THAT WAS
GOING TO TICK OFF A LOT OF
VOTERS AND PROGRESSIVES WERE
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM IT.
IT ALSO TICKED OFF A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS.
YOU SAW BOTH SIDES GETTING
FRUSTRATED.
I DON'T KNOW THA